Estamos ya en el problema 53 y dice Arturo está tratando de resolver esta ecuación,
completando el cuadrado y nos dan la ecuación ax cuadrada más bx más "c" igual a 0.
Donde el término "a" es
positivo, entonces nos dan varios pasos. Paso 1 me dice ax cuadrada más bx igual a - "c".
Esencialmente lo que hizo es restar "c" de ambos lados de esta ecuación.
Para que se cancele esta "c" y nos quede "c" del otro lado pero, con signo negativo.
Luego al siguiente paso lo que hizo fue dividir entre "a" por eso es
necesario pedirle, que al menos no sea 0 ¿Verdad? Entonces
al hacer el paso 2 divide entre "a" y nos quedó "x" cuadrada más "b" sobre ax
igual a -"c" sobre "a", todo lo anterior lo dividió sobre "a" y el paso 3 no lo tenemos.
La pregunta es ¿Cuál debería ser el paso 3 en la solución? Y en
esencialmente todo esto ya lo hemos visto en otros vídeos,
donde hablábamos de cómo completar él
el trinomio cuadrado perfecto, para poder deducir la ecuación o la fórmula cuadrática pero, bueno vamos a irlo haciendo. Tenemos
"x" cuadrada más "b" sobre ax
y vamos a tener, si queremos resolver la ecuación completando el cuadrado, tenemos que sumar algo.
Y que nos va a dar menos "c" sobre "a" y vamos a sumar eso mismo que sumemos del lado izquierdo.
Entonces ya lo hemos visto en unos vídeos atrás,
tenemos esencialmente que agregar la mitad de este número que tengo aquí que es "b" entre "a" y elevarlo al cuadrado. Lo elevamos al
cuadrado y eso es lo que vamos a sumar de ambos lados. Si no sabes de qué estoy hablando
quizás debería ser buena idea que veas el vídeo
de cómo completar los cuadrados o el trinomio cuadrado perfecto.
Entonces ¿Quién es la mitad de "b" entre "a"? Tenemos la mitad de "b" sobre "a",
y esto pues no es otra cosa más que "b" entre 2a, así que lo que tenemos que agregar,
tenemos que poner todo igual "x" cuadrada
más "b" sobre "a" por "x" y agregamos
"b" sobre 2a al cuadrado y eso si lo agrego del lado izquierdo lo tengo que agregar también aquí,
del lado derecho, para que la igualdad se conserve.
Entonces vamos a ver si con esta expresión, ya tenemos la solución.
Y sí está ¿Verdad? Es justo la opción D, la opción D, es justo esto que escribí aquí,
entonces
igual y de igual forma si no tuvo mucho sentido esto que hicimos para ti, entonces sería bueno que veas el vídeo de cómo completar el cuadrado.
Vamos al ejercicio 54.
¿Ok? Entonces nos dan cuatro pasos para deducir la fórmula cuadrática ¿Ok? Y se muestran aquí
abajo y nos preguntan ¿Cuál es el orden correcto
de estos pasos? Y si te das cuenta varios pasos ya los hicimos acá arriba. Acá arriba tenemos
este primer paso y luego este segundo paso,
vamos a ver y si los tenemos ¿Verdad? Este sería nuestro primer paso, este es nuestro primer paso aquí
fue el primero que realizamos,
o bueno de los primeros que realizamos ¿Verdad? Primero se resta "c" y luego se divide todo entre "a" y obtenemos este resultado.
En nuestro primer paso y después qué fue lo que hicimos, después sumamos
lo que me va a completar el trinomio cuadrado perfecto, que está de este lado es el
4 entonces, primero es el paso 1 y luego es el paso
4 y ahora ¿Qué es lo que sigue?
Bueno pues tenemos que notar que esto de la izquierda es un binomio al cuadrado, y ¿Cuál binomio al cuadrado? Pues el que tiene
"x" más este término y todo eso al cuadrado, es decir justo como acá y del lado derecho,
simplemente es simplificar esto ¿Verdad? Aquí si desarrollamos esto es "b" cuadrada entre 4a cuadrada y podemos sacar de común
denominador 4a cuadrada. Se resuelve esto y simplificamos y llegamos a esto ¿Verdad? Entonces
este sería mi me paso 3, ya no los voy a enmarcar.
Ok el paso, el siguiente paso es el 2 y bueno pues ya nada más nos queda el paso 3 ¿Verdad? Que es
sacar la raíz cuadrada.
Sacamos la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados y después restamos b entre 2a para despejar
"x" entonces vamos a ver si esta secuencia de paso se encuentra en nuestras opciones y es 1423
¡Ah! Justo es el inciso A 1423
Estuvo bastante bien ok, y bueno ya hemos dicho que se puede deducir la fórmula
completando la fórmula cuadrática, completando el binomio, el trinomio cuadrado perfecto ¿Verdad? Así que
esto simplemente es hacer ejercicios de eso mismo.
Nos preguntan cuál es una solución de la ecuación
2x cuadrada - x -4 igual a 0. Entonces si nos damos cuenta en las opciones se ve que no vamos a poder
factorizar, así que pues vamos a utilizar la fórmula cuadrática, y
realmente la fórmula cuadrática y si tenemos a "x" cuadrada más bx
más "c" igual a 0, entonces la solución está dada, está dada ¿Cómo qué?
Este es un polinomio en general ¿Verdad? Un polinomio de segundo grado el que sea
"a", "b" y c pues los tenemos que ajustar a nuestro caso particular pero, la solución está dada como - "b" más menos
la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada -4ac,
todo esto sobre
2a muy bien, entonces
simplemente hay que notar que "b" es -1, "a" es 2 y "c" es -4, así que si tomamos
este caso particular, tenemos que "b" es -1 así que tenemos menos -1
más menos la raíz de -1 al cuadrado
-4 por "a" que en este caso es 2
4 por 2 por "c" que es -4
-4 y todo eso lo dividimos entre 2a que es 2 por 2, ya de una vez voy a ponerlo como
4 muy bien, y esto simplemente es 1 más menos la raíz de
1 al cuadrado, bueno aquí tenemos -4 por 2 es -8 por -4 son
32 y si le sumamos -1 al cuadrado, que es 1 entonces tenemos la raíz de
33 todo esto, todo eso sobre
4 así que vamos a ver si alguna de estas soluciones se encuentra ya en nuestra lista.
Y sí, sí ésta está aquí ¿Verdad? Es la opción C, 1 más la raíz de
33 sobre 4. Si quisiéramos la otra es ponerle aquí un menos.
Vámonos con un ejercicio más 56 ¿Cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones explica mejor por que no hay soluciones
reales a la ecuación cuadrática 2x cuadrada más "x" más 7 igual a 0? Entonces
voy a poner nuevamente la
fórmula cuadrática es - b más menos
la raíz de cuadrada -4ac. Está ya para estas alturas te la deberías de memorizar, por que la estamos usando mucho.
Y si nos damos cuenta
la única forma para no tener soluciones es o sea todo está bien definido, todo está muy bien definido
excepto cuando lo que hay dentro de la raíz cuadrada es
negativo y eso es por que no podemos sacar raíces cuadradas de números negativos.
Así que cuando no hay solución, cuando "b" cuadrada -4ac es
menor que 0 es negativo. Ahí es donde se presentan todos los problemas. Vamos a ver qué pasa en este, en este ejemplo.
Tenemos,
aquí sería "b" cuadrada en este caso es 1 al cuadrado -4 que multiplica a "a",
que es 2 y luego multiplicar "c"  que es
7 y necesitamos que esto sea negativo, entonces de las opciones que nos dan me dice que, ese valor de hecho,
aquí bueno 1 al cuadrado es lo mismo ¿Verdad?.
Entonces 1 al cuadrado menos, 1 al cuadrado o 1, -4 por 2 por 7, debe ser negativo esa es la opción
correspondiente a que no haya soluciones reales ¿Verdad? A menos de que nos saltemos al
conjunto de los números imaginarios, pero ya ese es otro tema.
Entonces al menos en los números reales no hay soluciones cuando este número es negativo.
¿Ok? Así que yo creo que podemos irnos a un último ejercicio.
Dice ¿Cuál es el conjunto solución de la ecuación cuadrática 8x cuadrada más 2x más 1 igual a 0?
Entonces
yo creo que vamos a usar de una vez la fórmula cuadrática directamente. Entonces es -b que es -2
más menos la raíz de "b" cuadrada que es
2 al cuadrado, si es 2 al cuadrado -4
4 por "a" que es 8, por "c" que es 1 y creo que lo estoy haciendo,
creo que sí está bien, entonces
esto va sobre 2 por "a" que es 2 por 8,
entonces si esto lo desarrollamos esto es -2 más - la raíz de
4 - 4 por 8
32 y creo que está bien hasta este momento, sobre 2 por 8 que son
16 y bueno, si ya terminamos esto ya podrás ver que hay problemas ¿Verdad? Por que aquí sacamos la raíz de 4 -32
que son -28 sobre 16
entonces tenemos un problema severo,
por que tenemos la raíz de un número negativo, entonces la única forma de tener raíces
negativas es, si nos salimos del conjunto de los números reales y eso hasta este momento no lo estamos permitiendo.
Entonces la solución o más bien la respuesta, es que el conjunto solución es vacío, no hay
soluciones reales. Yo la verdad al inicio creí que nos habíamos equivocado pero, pero no la respuesta es que no hay soluciones reales.
¿Ok? Entonces no podemos tomar raíces cuadradas de números negativos y seguir siendo todavía un número real.  A ver veamos,
¿Habrá tiempo para otro más? No
mejor nos esperamos al siguiente vídeo. Nos vemos pronto.